I promise you I'm gonna take from him
what he took from you
he caught up with the Flash's superstar
Grant Gustin at the 2016 CW up front and
we've got the scoop on this week's sure
to be shocking season 2 finale I think
last year at fronts they asked me what
emoji I would use to describe it I did
water I said waterfall tears and I think
that's probably true for season two as
well we're gonna find out who is the man
in the iron mask what was your reaction
when you found out who it was I was
confused I was confirming bit Greg
brilliance he told me over the phone a
few months before he revealed it and I
was like okay wait explain this to me
explain this to me it's shocking it's
like last year where there's kind of
twist on top of twists so even anyone
that's kind of predicted reveals there's
something else on top that they haven't
thought of it's a really cool reveal as
for the fastest man alive future grants
build that he's ready to see bury
experience of happiness we want to see
the cocky fun hero that gets to kick
some ass not always get his ass kicked
and being kind of a fun positive place I
don't know how we're gonna get that
though next year now but hopefully he
can find his way there next year because
I think that's what I would like to see
for him you and I if this is shy yeah I
would like that yeah a relationship
bloom yeah for sure I mean I think he's
gonna need some support wherever you can
get it next year so love life would be
nice